manchin says republicans in normal times
will be supporting energy health and
health care bill this is a cnn story
democrat senator joe manchin argued
sunday that republicans would in normal
time support and energy and health care
ability recently negotiated with lead
with the
leaders of the party i think it's great
piece of legislation and on normal times
my republican colleagues would have been
uh
something such as this we basically pay
down the debt
which is what they want we've
accelerated permitting which is what
they want and we've increased production
of energy which is what they want
we've done things that we should be
doing together mention also defending
the prohibition in a bill that would
impose a 15 minimum tax on certain
corporations these are the bigger
corporations out there and they said
taxes won't be going up but yeah i think
it is going up schumer mansion a deal
raises taxes on earners under four
hundred thousand dollars the energy and
health care bill from mansion and
schumer would raise taxes on millions of
americans earning less than four hundred
thousand dollars annually
uh senate republican says citing
nonpartisan data the congressional joint
committee on taxation found that taxes
would jump by 16.7 billion dollars on
american payers making less than 200 000
in 2023 and raise another 14.1 billion
on taxpayers who make between two to
five hundred thousand dollars during the
ten year window the average tax rate
would go up for most american categories
by 2031 new energy credits and subsidies
would have people earning less than 400
000 uh pay as much as two-thirds of the
additional tax revenue collected this
year the measure would raise
739 billion over 10-year span with much
of money coming from a 15 corporate
minimum tax rate okay what are your
thoughts on this would mention well just
goes to show that joe manchin controls
the united states right now okay uh he
shot down uh biden's buildback better
deal that two trillion dollar
uh proposed
bill that went nowhere
and him and chuck schumer behind closed
doors worked this out
so uh it's basically a skinny down
version of the build back better deal
and
listen whether you like it or not this
is a win for the biden administration
okay
biden's had a pretty good week you know
despite having coped twice in the past
two weeks
killed the uh
what's uh osama bin laden's number two
guy
you should get sick and do nothing more
often hey exactly
so um
you know i'm a big fan of joe manchin
and uh you know what do they say killers
move in silence and he's he's a straight
killer he's he's the type of person that
we need more of in this country willing
to
work behind closed doors and put your
partisan aside i've always said this and
i'll say it again
any democrat that can consistently get
elected in the reddest state in the
country watch what that man is doing
there's some magic to mansion
and uh he did it again tom
i i think this is an old school bill
in the you know if you if you read your
history
old school congress used to always ask
how are you going to pay for that right
how are you going to pay for that
because the automatic just flopping over
and
impaling
the
the national debt with more debt wasn't
automatic they they took great care in
there and they took great care about
raising the debt ceiling they weren't so
lazy fair about it or were they debate
threatened to shut down the government
for three weeks and then they raised a
debt ceiling anyway this is an
old-school bill and he's to pay for
these things we need these things and i
you know
i think the bill was kind of balanced
because there's a corporate tax on it
and there's also a change to income tax
so he's like everybody needs to pay for
this and i think that's probably how
schumer
that's probably that the tax for
everybody is how manson agreed to it
because schumer's not a tax guy schumer
just wants the program spending that's
in it and he
mansion was like hey we got to adjust it
with taxes so that this thing kind of
pays for itself that's twice
so it's like
that's what i think about it i think
it's your old school bill where they're
actually they're actually being
responsible pbd where they're like hey
we got some programs over here and
people are going to pay for it you know
what happened to the wealthy they taxed
everybody including corporates you know
what i like about what bro asked him he
said uh well what are you gonna do if
they come back and they do this and they
do that and they do this says well let
me tell you what i told uh president
biden uh about this bill if you have to
keep your word and i have to keep my
word
if they do their part and i do my part
everything's gonna be fine but if they
don't i've shown my track record that
i'm not going to vote on certain things
so they have to do their part and keep
their word i thought it was pretty
impressive that he publicly also put it
out there that hey
you play too much politics i'm not
playing the games when it comes down to
these types of policies vinny
while while you read that all that kept
hitting me is because i'm the under 400
000. i'm under the 200 000. i'm gonna it
just keeps going up right it's saying
it's going to go up and then it's going
to go back 2023 they're going to raise
it another 14 billion another 10-year
window it's going to go up another so
everybody that's under 400 000 is going
to be getting taxed over and over and
over and over right that's that's all
i'm seeing is that the it's not just the
rich now they're they're going to tax
the [ __ ] out of everybody it's uh yes
it's a 16.7 billion american taxpayers
making less than two hundred thousand
dollars in 2023. yeah so
oh go ahead sorry 16.7 billion is money
it is they're being taxed there's no
question about it how much you know very
minimal but you're going to be your
taxes went up so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]